What's an API?
What's an SDK?
And how arethe two related?
How can APIs and SDKs help streamline my cloud app development workflows?
I'm Nathan Hekman from IBM Cloud
and before I jump in and answer that for you,
please hit thatsubscribe button.
Alright, let's get started with an example.
Let's say you're developing a mobileapp for a veterinarian clinic,
and the idea is for this mobile app to actually
allow a receptionistto take a picture of a pet as it enters the clinic
and the app will communicatewith a visual recognition service
that's running on the cloud.
And the idea is for the service to return the pet's name and bring up their file.
So, how do we do this? How do we communicate
between the mobile app and this cloud-basedservice?
Well, that's where APIs and SDKs comein.
Let's get started by talking about APIs,
and we'll actually be comparing the two.
So, firstof all, APIs are all about communication.
So, there are a set of definitions and protocols
for apps or services to talk to other apps or services.
So, you can kind of think of them like abridge between your app
and, say, this cloud-based visual recognition service.
So, what does "API" standfor anyway?
Well, it's Application Programming interface - A.P.I.
And whatare some of the aspects ofAPIs that make them useful?
Well, like I saidthey're they're all about communication.
So, communicating between a service and anotherservice, an app and another app,
it's it's how they talk to each other.
Next, they're all about abstraction.
What does "abstraction" mean?
So, inside the VR service, up in the cloud,
there's probably potentiallythousands of lines of code running up there,right?
And you as a developer of a mobileapp you don't want to have to worry about,
"OK, which method in this service do I call to getthe pet's name?"
You don't want to have to worry about that.
So, what an API does is it abstractsaway all that complicated logic
so you just have to worry about getting just the
data you need.
It simplifies the process.
And third, APIs are standardized.
Meaning, there's industry-defined standards
for how to define an API
and there's a few formats that are popular for APIs.
Youmay have heard of SOAP, GraphQL, or REST,
- which, fun fact, stands for "Representational State
Transfer",
and that's what we'll focus on for this video.
So, what are some of the buildingblocks of APIs?
First of all, to actually send data, or send what's called a "request"
fromthe mobile app to the VR service on the cloud
you need to have a few different pieces.
So,for a REST API call request you need to have
what's called an operation.
So this is this could be HTTP methods like POST,PUT, GET, DELETE.
In this case it would be a POST method
because you're sending a requestover to the service
which might include something like maybe the file name
ofthe image you took of the pet.
Next, would be parameters, this is optional.
So, this, in this case, might be the file name of the image you took.
So maybe cat.jpeg - if it's a cat that you took a picture of.
And finally, would be the endpoint.
So, that's the URL,basically,
of the visual recognition servicethat you're trying to talk to.
So, maybethat's, you know, it's some URL-slash-analyze.
Great, so that's your request, right?
So, this is what makes up a request.
How about a response?
What might a RESTAPI response call that you receive back
from the visual recognition service look like?
Typically it's it'ssome form of raw data, maybe JSON.
So, a request might look something like,
orsorry, a RESPONSE, might look something like this.
So, you have sort of this this dataobject that might include
you know, the result, the type which is a cat,
and maybe the name -
which, in this case may be "Mittens" just walked into theclinic.
Great, so that's sort of the buildingblocks of what an API is.
As a developer though, how do you actually call an API in yourcode?
You don't want to have to worry about
setting up your request with all these buildingblocks of operations, parameters, endpoints,
and dealing with raw JSON objects, right?
So that's where SDKs come in and really shine.
So, let's talk about SDKs, what doesthat stand for?
Well it is SoftwareDevelopment Kit, S.D.K.
Pretty straightforward,right?
So, SDKs, you can really think of like atoolbox
of tools, or code that actually callAPIs for you.
Pretty cool, right?
So, you may be specialized in oneprogramming language over the other,
you know, there's SDKs in a variety of languages.
So, there's maybe an SDK in Java, in Node,
maybe Go,
or Python -
whichever language that isyour specialty there's probably an SDKfor you.
Perfect. So, back to our example overhere,
what might an SDK look like in this example?
So, with an SDK, let's let's go ahead and putour little SDK toolbox
within the mobile app
and, for this case, since it's a mobile app,
say,we'll use the Java SDK. Great!
So, in this Java SDK,
rather than having to configure
yourrequest manually with all these building blocks, you might actually call
just a method, that'smaybe called, I don't know, "Get Result",
that will actually call these various buildingblocks -
the operation, the parameters,
and the request for you,
it'll make it for youand it'll make that API request for you with code.
In response, you'll get a responsebut it won't be necessarily a JSON object,
it might be some code,
maybe a nativemodel object in Java called an "Analyze Response Object".
So, the code might look somethinglike this.
So, you have an Analyze Response Object
that you call the "Visual Recognition Analyze and Get Results" method.
You pass in a parameter, which is "cat.jpg", which is the name ofthe file
that you sent over the visual recognition service
and, in response, you can actually go aheadand set
a label in your mobile app to be "Mittens".
So, that's the data you received in theform of an analyze response model object in Java,
via your SDK, and you're able to seeMittens has entered the building.
So, hopefully, this kind of summarizeswhat's an API, what's an SDK,
what are both used for,
and how they are truly fundamentaltools in your cloud app development toolbox.
Thank you.
If you have questions, please drop usa line below.
If you want to see more videos like this in the future, please "like" and subscribe.
And don't forget, you can grow your skills and earn a badge with IBM CloudLabs,
which arefree browser-based interactive Kubernetes labs.